how the New Deal continues to affect
human rights foreign policy and the
global economy from this year's
Roosevelt reading festival at the FDR
Presidential Library this is 40 minutes
good morning everybody welcome this is
the session in which we meet Elizabeth
board Ward and her wonderful book new
deals for the world America's vision for
human rights I'd like to talk a little
bit about this book because i have i
have read it and i love it because in
this fascinating book she describes how
a cadre of world war two American
planners inaugurated the ideas and the
institutions that underlie our modern
human rights regime she finds the key in
the nineteen forty one Atlantic Charter
and it's anglo-american vision for war
and peace I am analyzing the interaction
of ideas individuals and institutions in
the 1940s the transformed American
foreign policy and American view of
themselves she illuminates the broader
history of modern human rights trade and
the global economy collective security
and international law you may think they
knew this is her first book and it's a
wonderful book it was published by
Harvard University Press and has
garnered the Murrell kurti book award
from the Organization of American
Historians and as the best book in the
history of ideas for 2006 elizabeth is
also a lawyer she has a JD from Harvard
Law School school and a master's in
philosophy in international relations
from Cambridge University where she also
took her ba in modern history she was an
affiliate of the Charles Warren Center
for the Study of American history at
Harvard in two thousand six and two
thousand seven and we'll start as an
associate professor in the Department of
History at washington university in st.
louis this fall but she then we'll go as
a full price on distinguished lecturer
to the center of MIT for American
Studies at the University of Heidelberg
in Germany where I suspect she'd be
getting to work or continuing to work on
her next book which is a history of the
Nuremberg trials so it's a real pleasure
and an honor to have such a great
scholar with us this morning Elizabeth
bored bored good morning I feel like I
shouldn't say anything after that
introduction there's nowhere to go but
down thanks to Cynthia cook director of
the FDR library for that very generous
introduction a couple of the quick thank
yous and to cliff lobby for organizing
this wonderful event the Roosevelt
readings festival and thanks to my to my
publicist Ellen Kaplan Sulkin who's here
today do you see her afterwards she'll
give you a little bookmark and and
finally thanks also to Bob Clark and the
other challenged archivists here at the
FDR library they help me conduct the
research that led to this book and
they're helping me now with my next book
as dr. crook mentioned on on on the
Nuremberg trials so this little book
talk actually has a title because it's
called FDR and the Atlantic Charter of
nineteen forty one is a human rights
instrument colon once you stayed a moral
principle you are stuck with it and you
may be relieved that I'm not going to
read from the book a friend of mine who
is reading it now accosted nations well
I'm on page 38 she said I hope you don't
read that page she says that or this one
either but I think it's more interesting
to just tell some stories from the book
and put a little sort of meat on the
bones offer a specific slice of the
books approach rather than trying to
offer a more general flyover because it
is kind of a big book and I'm going to
speak for about 20-25 minutes and i'm
told only 10 minutes of questions which
is sad for me because that's my favorite
part but i hope you will think of a
question and if it doesn't work out for
you to ask it here i hope you'll find me
afterwards they have these little table
system so we can talk then
so I want to use this specific document
as a jumping off point as I mentioned in
my title the atlantic charter of august
1941 this is a very short document it's
fewer than 400 words and i mean if you
think about it an op-ed write an
editorial in a newspaper would be about
seven hundred words six or seven hundred
words so 400 words really quite brief
and it's divided into eight points and
it was negotiated bilaterally
british-american between FDR and Winston
Churchill and it's a statement as noted
of war and peace aims so why would let's
have just I used to teach in law school
so let's have a little Socratic moment
here this is an extraordinary thing for
FDR to be doing right why is it so
extraordinary for him to be negotiating
war and peace aims in august of 1941
anybody anybody great exact to see this
I knew this would be a good crowd it's
four months before pearl harbor right
America's not in the war so he's really
taking a very big risk here the actual
negotiations are unfolding under
conditions of utmost secrecy but they
come back and they make an announcement
of what they've negotiated and so FDR is
really making quite a big statement by
not only what war aims might look like
but what a future postwar world might
look like again before the United States
is even in them even in the war so let
me offer a little little vignette here
just to kind of make things more vivid
the sunny Sunday morning of August 10th
1941 found President Franklin Roosevelt
making his longest public walk since
having contracted polio almost exactly
20 years earlier and he's walking along
the the very long quarterdeck of this
british battleship the Prince of Wales
seem to be sunk in the Pacific actually
very sadly and he's walking to attitude
to the end of this quarter deck to
attend
british american religious service
Sunday service that's going to be held
on the deck that's been very carefully
stage-managed by British Prime Minister
Winston Churchill on the second morning
of this three and a half day conference
that they're having together FDR
Churchill and members of their senior
diplomatic and military staff and under
as i mentioned conditions of the utmost
secrecy in placentia bay off the coast
of newfoundland and they hadn't met
before or at least they certainly hadn't
met as leaders of their respective
qualities there's a little controversy
about that they probably did meet at a
dinner right towards the end of World
War one when of course Churchill was
already in the cabinet Roosevelt was
only 36 to 37 and Churchill supposedly
kind of gave him the brush-off a little
bit Roosevelt course remembered every
every slight but Churchill professed not
to remember so there was a sort of tacit
agreement that they were just going to
start again they had been corresponding
of course for some time but this was
their first real meeting and Churchill
of course has much longer and more
dangerous journey across the u-boat
infested waters of the North Atlantic to
attend in off the coast of Newfoundland
there and he's speculating all the way
during that journey Harry Hopkins is
actually traveling with him traveling
with Churchill and he hecho later wrote
no lover ever contemplated every whim of
his mistress as I you know studied those
of President Roosevelt so along this
quarter deck where Roosevelt is making
his way there are also 1,500 British and
American sailors a raid you know to also
be a part of this service and that's how
we know so much about this scene because
Roosevelt is of course he's not really
walking in a sense right he's sort of
almost moving his body so as to simulate
walking he has of course as he once put
it towards the end of his presidency 10
pounds of Steel on the lower part of his
legs course tremendously powerful upper
body and he could kind of point you know
swing yes I
he's got a cane in one hand and he's
balancing on the arm of his son Elliot a
naval officer one of his sons and as
he's walking along his aides of course
thought this was a terrible idea what if
the boat pitched what if the president
fell what if he laughed the strength to
complete what really was quite a long
journey and so these sailors who are
arrayed on the deck are watching this in
silence as they said the heat some of
their diary entries making his painful
way that they could see what it cost him
to take this long walk and there of
course standing at attention but many of
them have you know tears running down
their faces they're so moved to see the
president making this effort and it
sends an incredible nonverbal message of
solidarity right because again United
States not in the war so Britain in the
United States not yet wartime Ali's
allies but it sends this incredible
message of solidarity without a word
being spoken very very dramatic scene so
Churchill has very carefully chosen the
hymns and readings to go with this
Sunday service emphasizing schemes of
duty loyalty and unstinting support to
those in need no fool Churchill the
verse was drawn from Joshua as I was
with Moses social I'd be with v I will
not fail thee nor forsake thee and FDR
later dictated a diary entry which is
unusual behavior for FDR for those of
you who are FDR scholars and in this
audience and I see several and you know
not a super reflective guy and so just
him making a diary entry and sort of
communicates that he himself had an
immediate sense of the historical
importance of this meeting and he said
in that entry that even if nothing else
had happened at this summit that that
Sunday morning service the religious
service would have cemented us would
have cemented Britain in the United
States so this meeting on board the
Prince of Wales and actually also on
board a British a US destroyer the USS
Augusta actually most of actual meetings
took place on the Augusta their pulled
up side by side one result of this
meeting was this so-called joint
declaration that I mentioned earlier the
Atlantic Charter which was released to
the world as a telegram press release
very informal for given the diplomacy of
the time I'm not going to read you the
eight points but I just want to group
them thematically just so you get a feel
for what they were talking about the
first group of points were what I call
so a rehash of some traditional
wilsonian ideas about international
relations I'm particularly emphasizing
ideas about self-determination in other
words saying that the war was not being
fought for territorial aggrandizement
that any carrots boundary changes that
resulted from the war would be in accord
with principles of self-determination
again good wilsonian language a second
set of points talking about advocating a
free trade and disarmament under the
auspices of a very vaguely designated
collective security organization all
right well this is the first reference
to what we now know as the United
Nations and Roosevelt wanted this very
vague this language collective security
organization because of course he was
very sensitive given the surrounding
situation that I just outlined it beats
four months before Pearl Harbor very
sensitive to his strong and powerful
isolationist constituencies domestically
and so he doesn't want to be too
specific in terms of something that
might sound a little too much like the
League of Nations and then a third group
of points which concern you the most for
the purposes of the rest of this
presentation promoting promoting
development of the human personality
right which is this great new dealer
term and things like improved Labor
Standards economic advancement social
security and the most lyrical which i'm
just going to paraphrase for you quickly
is that at the end of the war that these
two great nations hope to see a piece
where after the final defeat of Nazi
tyranny all nations may dwell in safety
within their own boundaries and which a
piece which will afford assurance that
all the men in all the lands may live
out their lives and
freedom from fear and what ok it's a
very familiar language to Roosevelt fans
we say something about FDR's objectives
for this document for the Atlantic
Charter earlier in 1941 FDR had
expressed some interest in and this is
his language some kind of public
statement of the objectives and
international relations in which the
government of the United States believed
that would advance the cause of keeping
alive some principles of international
law some principles of moral and human
decency okay again this is very unusual
language for FDR to talk explicitly
about international law he's of course
himself a lawyer trained at Columbia but
he's also responding to one of his close
aides Hadley Cantrell urging him to
develop a statement of war aims that
would educate the American public about
the personal effects of a Nazi victory
and ideology in other words what would
it really be like for the American
people if the Nazis won in Europe are
not unrealistic prospect in the middle
of 1941 and also what he means by the
Four Freedoms ok so the previous January
in his annual message to Congress which
we now more familiarly call the State of
the Union address FDR had proclaimed and
i know this is familiar to you right
that he sought to establish four
essential human freedoms everywhere in
the world and i just want to highlight
this for one second though because i
think that fdr's original framing it's
very different than i think what's come
down to us sort of culturally there's a
received vision of the Four Freedoms is
Rockwell's vision right Norman
Rockwell's vision his office of War
Information paintings which then became
posters of the Four Freedoms but FDR
initial frame is very different these
are the four students of course speech
and worship and freedom from want and
freedom from fear but they were
explicitly international in fact FDR
wrote in in his own handwriting after
each freedom percussively he would say
you know everywhere in the world
everywhere in the world and his own
advisers were frankly dubious about this
framing Harry Hopkins
listen to FDR's draft and said you know
mr. president I really don't think that
the American people are going to be that
interested in the Four Freedoms for the
people of Java to which FBI reportedly
replied well they're going to have to be
some day Harry so they might as well
start now and whereas of course
Rockwell's vision as we know was pretty
much exclusively domestic right in both
senses of that term domestic in a sense
of not international and domestic in a
sense of images of home and hearth as
war aims as what we're fighting for and
in fact there's only just one tiny
international reference if you can even
call at that in Rockwell's vision of the
Four Freedoms write a few if I can just
evoke this one for you they're so iconic
but the freedom from fear image where
there's a young couple sort of safely
tucking their children into their little
rooftop loft very modest bedroom and the
father has a folded newspaper that says
blitz bombing of London right and so
there's a sort of subtext of you know
isn't it nice that we can safely talk
our children into this you know wooden
roof top bedroom without having to worry
about you know bombs falling on their
heads but again it sucks that's pretty
subtle so both the four freedoms and the
Atlantic Charter were framed in a
deliberately fear idiom right there
aspirational their motivational they
accordingly meant very different things
to different people and I want to use
the central part of this presentation
just to quickly contrast three different
constituencies that were basically
receiving this document right the
Atlantic Charter and transforming it for
their own for their own purposes and
sending around a controversy of to whom
should the Atlantic Charter apply okay
well it sounds like sort of a strange
question but this is a very
controversial issue in the second half
of 1941 and throughout 1942 and it's
tied to this idea of the transformation
of human rights ideas but I'm going to
conclude with so one of FDR's
speechwriters the Pulitzer prize-winning
playwright Robert Sherwood he said that
it was not fair
long before the people of India Burma
Malaya and Indonesia were beginning to
ask if the Atlantic Charter extended to
the Pacific and to Asia in general okay
well this this prompts an exasperated
series of press conferences that FDR
gives where he says you know we called
it the Atlantic Charter because we were
meeting in the Atlantic and of course it
applies all around the world and that's
actually my favorite illustration in my
book is a line drawing of a political
cartoon from 1942 with FDR some iconic
looking FDR with his jaunty cigarette
holder pulling a kind of stretchy
atlantic charter all around all around
the globe furthermore the charters
referenced individuals in its famous
points6 the one that i just paraphrase
to you this language about all the men
in all the lands because really sound
like that big a deal right but this
would be an obvious place in an
international instrument to refer to you
know High Contracting sovereign parties
blah blah blah and it doesn't do that
and earlier drafts did actually and so
this oblique reference to individuals I
mean men is obviously meant to be you
know people is it has a simplistic
corollary okay is a little attenuated
but i hope to stick with me that
individuals creek now somehow be an
appropriate object of international
concern and I mean this is definitely
one interpretation of this language this
specific issue of individuals was seized
upon by a young black lawyer in South
Africa in 1941 named Nelson Mandela
right Nelson Mandela is so old that he
was already a lawyer in 1941 and he's
written very movingly about specifically
about the Atlantic Charter in his
memoirs he said the Atlantic Charter of
1941 signed by Roosevelt and Churchill
reaffirmed faith in the dignity of each
human being ok so there's the early
human rights link right this idea of
individual human dignity this becomes
huge as an interpretation some in the
West saw the Charter is empty promises
but not those of us in Africa inspired
by the Atlantic Charter and the sight of
allies against tyranny and oppression
the African National Congress created
its own charter we hope that the
government and ordinary South Africans
would see that the principles they were
fighting for in Europe were the ones
that we were advocating at home so this
idea that individual citizens could
somehow have a direct relationship to
some kind of supra national
international legal order would hold
obvious appeal right for subjects of
oppressive regimes the world over so
this is one interpretation of the
Atlantic Charter is a kind of early
anti-colonial instrument unsurprisingly
Nelson Mandela's Atlantic Charter was
not Winston Churchill's right Churchill
noted rather testily in response to an
Indian pamphlet pamphlet here charging
him with hypocrisy and the month right
after the Atlantic Charter was
promulgated he said at the Atlantic me
I'm not going to do the voice okay he's
at the Atlantic meeting we had in mind
primarily the restoration of the
sovereignty self-government and national
life of the states and nations of Europe
now under the Nazi yoke ok so for
Churchill charter as an inspirational
polemic targeted British morale and the
morality invaded countries of Europe and
what I've served figuratively been
calling Mandela's charter so really a
much more radical conception of
international law they recognized the
standing of the individual at least
potentially unmediated by the
intervening level of a sovereign state
so FDR speechwriter sure word commented
about this controversy that to the
surprise of Churchill and the British
occasionally when you state a moral
principle you are stuck with it right
that's for my child come from no matter
how many fingers you may have crossed
behind your back at the time so what
about FDR's Atlantic Charter his
contribution was to emphasize an
explicit infusion of aspirational
economic rights and I think you can get
a feeling for what was new here by
projecting ourselves back to the
historical moment in 1941 when the
realities of oncoming war right on
coming obviously from the American
perspective not from the British are
colliding with the ideologies of the
mature new deal and sort of resulting in
this really interesting product that the
Atlantic Charter another section of FDR
same 1940
one for freedom speech spelled out the
president's basic ideas about things
expected by their people of their
political and economic systems and this
was this part of the speech was
reprinted and repackaged in a very
widely distributed pamphlet called your
economic Bill of Rights you may even
have seen this pamphlet your economic
Bill of Rights will just quickly what
are some of your economic Bill of Rights
I mean just because they're so great and
it's we're so far from them now here are
some of them for everyone equal access
to minimum security as well as to the
adventures of civilization okay the
language is also fantastic for everyone
food shelter and clothing on an American
minimum standard who hello so for
everyone in the world that I guess right
hard to say for everyone a job at a fair
wage if he is in the labor market and a
guarantee against joblessness for
everyone a guarantee of protection
against accident and disease just a
couple more for everyone a guarantee of
protection against old age good news
that's the actual language and finally
for everyone an opportunity for
recreation and the cultural activities
appropriate to his time against the
floor astonishing list I think one
measure of the extent to which our own
sensibilities about the certainly
Western discourse of human rights had
been shaped by Cold War inspired shifts
right would later Cold War inspired
shifts is the capacity of a new deal
inspired catalog such as this one to
surprise us and so and I think that
linking all these ideas together
particularly in an international
instrument such as the Atlantic Charter
was a new deal inspired contribution
right just as the new deal and again
painting with the broadest brush right
because I realized I'm here with an
audience of expert what the new deal was
about reconfiguring the notion of
security for the individual citizen so
this internationalized vision of the
four freedoms and the Atlantic Charter
can be construed as an attempted
projection of New Deal approaches on to
the wider world stage reframing
international security as having
explicit social justice dimensions okay
so after Pearl Harbor Churchill's back
they decide to bra
they have another summit with Roosevelt
they decide to broaden in December of 41
spilling into January 42 their statement
of Alliance they incorporate the
Atlantic Charter by specific reference
they make a much more specific reference
to the idea of Human Rights they use the
term at last as something that they're
fighting for and they open this new
document which somewhat confusingly is
called the declaration by United Nations
right we know there's no United Nations
the way we think of it back in 1942 but
this was Roosevelt's preferred name for
the anti access military alliance so
this declaration by United Nations Mme
broaden out analytically here in
conclusion is i think the first
multilateral statement of the four key
elements of a transformed anti-access
reading of the term human rights it is
of course a much older term and that's
why I'm emphasizing themes of
transformation right I'm not saying
human rights are somehow invented by
these two but but these four elements
included I would say one highlighting
traditional political rights as core
values right right things that you'd
find in the u.s. bill of rights for
instance about political participation
and freedom of speech secondly
incorporating a broader vision of
so-called four freedoms rights which
included specific references to economic
justice thirdly at least suggesting that
the subjects included individuals as
well as the more traditional unit of
sovereign nation states as this Mandela
reading that I was highlighting earlier
and finally fourth emphasizing that
these principles applied internationally
as well as domestically and again that's
sort of the anti-colonial overlay and
I'd submit that this synthesis was
something new Under the Sun in early
1940s diplomacy that all 4 and that all
4 elements continue to inform our modern
understanding our contemporary
understanding of the term international
human rights so wrapping up even a short
presentation such as this one would not
be complete without saying something at
least briefly about the question of
Allied hypocrisy right in January 1942
ok the very same month just wonderful
human rights Proclamation is
made leaders in Nazi Germany are meeting
at the so-called von say conference
right which is very widely held to be
the formal initiation of the phase of
the so-called final solution which we
now know as the Holocaust this very same
month obviously coincidentally but is
the initial promulgation it's not signed
but it's drafted and agreed to of the
Japanese relocation order we locate
forcibly relocating proxima 135,000
residents US residents of Japanese
descent many of whom very high
proportion of whom were US citizens
having all these events happen together
I think emphasizes why it's important
continually to juxtapose discussions of
ideas and language right with lived
realities and reacting to this initial
1942 declaration Mohandas Gandhi wrote
to FDR in 1942 July mention 42 and said
I venture to think that the Allied
declaration that the Allies are making
the world safe for democracy sounds
Hollow so long as India and this is
again Gandhi's language and for that
matter Africa are exploited by Great
Britain and America has the Negro
problem in her own home again Gandhi's
framing and I think this letter
underscores how where historical actors
themselves sometimes are of these
yawning gap between rhetoric and reality
and that awareness of this dissonance
can sometimes be in an engine of
historical change in its own right
precisely in order to to narrow the gap
so I want to just leave you with a
little image of the Atlantic Charter as
as a human rights symbol and this is a
quote from Churchill that I think
unwittingly captures the the power of
the Charter and I say unwittingly
because it's from a conversation with
FDR where he's trying to sort of wiggle
out from under the perceived strictures
of the Atlantic Charter he's arguing the
Atlantic Charter is not a contract but
it's not legally binding and of course
to me as an international lawyers
hilarious conversation because of course
it's not legally binding right any more
than you could bring the Declaration of
Independence into a court of law and say
you know enforce this
being violated but also not a document
without a certain salience right in our
national political culture so anyway
Churchill says to FDR that the Atlantic
Charter is not a law it is a star but
sometimes we are bound more by our stars
and by our laws thank you very much and
I'm very happy thank you that's very
nice is that just for these founders
Tucker me I'm very happy to take your
questions and I think they want you to
come up to the mic if you don't mind I'm
sorry
and dr. cook will you tell us when we
need to be done or what some look at
writing Thank You hi when FDR in
Churchill agreed to go to the to meet in
the Atlantic did they both have the same
goal oh the Atlantic I have a couple
degrees did they leave with the same
goal haha considering that the Atlantic
Charter is quite a blow to colonialism
Oh did Churchill agree to this because
he really needed Roosevelt help and last
question I have is two more because the
copy that's out in the exhibition the
copy that's outside in the exhibition
FDR commander-in-chief freedom from fear
it looks like Roosevelt signed
Churchill's name these are great
questions and then one day he is very
telling yes well ok yes they they
definitely did not have the same goals
and of course in Churchill's dreams the
best would have been for the United
States to make some kind of formal
declaration of Alliance and I think he
knew that that wasn't going to happen
and he wanted a much firmer declaration
of related to Japan he wanted convoys to
continue as far as ice when he had
certain specific goals in mind some of
which were met most of which were not
FDR was the one who really wanted the
Atlantic Charter because of course it
was big it was inspirational it was it
was very Roosevelt asked in many ways
and Churchill who was absolutely
brilliant negotiator and the first part
of my book is a sort of almost
microanalysis of how this negotiation
unfolds about what's actually in the
Charter Churchill basically holds up the
Atlantic Charter for some other things
that he wants and he's well I can't
agree to that you know without the
cabinet is signing off and all the
dominions and you know that'll take
weeks and if it so Roosevelt doesn't
want that British Cabinet convenes at
two o'clock in the morning London time
and get the cable of the Atlantic
Charter and they actually send it back
it's the british cabinet in the middle
of the night who adds the language about
freedom from fear and scream from
warrant because they thought that
Roosevelt would like that so as a very
interesting backstory they know they had
very different goals and Roosevelt
trying to sort of stave off firmer
commitments the anti-colonial overlay i
think was not obvious
either of them Frank I have to say at
the moment of negotiating there was a
later interpretation that you know
Churchill was very irritated by and this
your last question about that the the
original which is of course a cable
right it was a telegram is signed by
Roosevelt he signed his own name and
then he finds Churchill's name and just
quickly this becomes a very big
controversy because of course Americans
we love to sort of fetishize original
documents the historian Colleen mayor
who has a wonderful book about the
Declaration of Independence says that
you know the declaration of independence
in the Constitution they're like what
Lenin body was to the former Soviet you
you know people go and it's all
religious looking shrine and so not
having was not got a question about
where's the original and he said well
there really is no original and he sort
of told the story of why there was no
original and people were very upset you
know the ante Roosevelt press just
pilloried him it was a visa world they'd
document their fake principle precisely
because there was no original with both
of their signatures so that's a terrific
question thank you thank you
good if you could just would you prefer
different they have a handheld mic for
you yes that would be better
thank you very much this is much easier
my name is Christopher sure Wonka thank
you so much for your very enlightening
lecture today question I have for you
more deals with the present day
implications of the Roosevelt human
rights legacy with all of the things
that we see going on at one tanem obey
and things of that nature do you think
that the legacy of her shell and
roosevelt and hispanic charters being
disgraced be smart or otherwise
diminished by current events another
great question i have a you know a long
section towards the end of new deal for
the world about sort of present day
legacies of some of these ideas and you
know one of the problems of having very
as i said very general thin rhetoric is
that it can be appropriated right for
various kinds of different purposes and
the Four Freedoms made a recent
appearance in the last not the last one
but the one before state of the [ __ ]
state of the union address the surprise
guest appearance right by the Four
Freedoms in obviously a very different
context and actually dr. crook was
telling me that at the Reagan Library
there are five pillars and that they're
supposed to be the Four Freedoms plus I
don't know something else and that dr.
Kirk was asking about is where these
come from it oh they come from Norman
Rockwell's paintings just like oh yeah
and then we added one because you know
we wanted it to be different issue all
right great so I mean the point being
that I think once something gets
internalized to the into the culture
there are all kinds of different
directions that it can go in you know
and I think that even my own book
frankly I was looking for some I needed
to print out reviews of the book you
know for tenure and you know how do you
know who is your viewing your book no
one ever sends you that I here are your
Brooke and I hated it you know you never
get anything like that so I was looking
around online and there's the book is
quoted in a very you know sort of
vitriolic anti New Deal position paper
by the heritage foundation for the
proposition that you know FDR
know what he was doing when he
negotiated the Atlantic Charter that it
was so contingent and that just involve
evolved by chance and of course you know
when your historian you're sort of
trying to create a little texture and a
little sense of tension and you know so
that's now the proposition that the book
is being excited for so yes I mean I
think that it's it's obviously some of
the developments that you've referenced
I think would be what we like to say
without CD antithesis but then we we
look at japanese-american internment
right but in terms of I think the the
pressure that our political system is
under particularly our bill of rights
during wartime I think it's a very
instructive contrast in many ways I'll
say diplomatically and not in some other
ways again because of Japanese
internment but i think the sense that
people need to be inspired and feel like
they're fighting for something that's
aspirational has come that sense has
come to this administration very wait
you know that the original excuse for
war in iraq was was weapons of mass
destruction and other kinds of security
related issues but they very quickly
transformed when those issues turned out
to not work out so well into you know
that we're fighting for the human rights
of iraqi people particularly rocky
afghan women and having that this had
much more purchase with the american
people than these other kinds of
rationales and i think it was a
diminished i mean i think that
intentions matter i think is the bottom
line and not just language but we're
still seeing a lot of these ideas and
indeed this very language in line with
your great question around today thank
you i'm sorry i'm making my answers very
long i think they can bring a mic to you
actually if you're okay right Thank You
hi thank you as Eleanor Roosevelt
carried on the human rights work after
the war so strongly I wondered was she
involved in conversation with FDR about
human rights at this time or what is her
involvement Oh a great question um
and I I think she was involved in terms
of just her general influence on FDR at
this time particularly around the fair
employment practices committee of trying
to have african american labor treated
fairly domestically in in terms of war
work or employment war contracts defense
contracts she was very active in sort of
tugging him to the left but in terms of
the specifics around the negotiation of
the atlantic charter not only was she
not active if she wasn't there and she
didn't even know about it he snuck out
of Washington didn't tell Eleanor had
Secret Service people and I tell the
story and in the book as I need to can't
talk about everything but he had Secret
Service people impersonating him FDR did
on the Potomac the presidential yacht
Potomac in hyannis day where he was
supposedly having a fishing vacation
during these negotiations and so they've
got a Secret Service guy you know with a
cigarette holder and fall on sending
back bulletins about how many fish they
caught and of course FDR is off off the
coast of New Zealand and so as she was
actually mighty irritated that she
literally didn't even know where he was
anyway thank you very much for your kind
attention I'm happy to talk with you
more outside a new deal for the world
this program was part of the 2007
Roosevelt Reading Festival for more
information visit FDR library dot marist
dot edu